[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's the sound of BMWs M 760li X drive
BMWs most powerful vehicle today it
boasts a brand new M Performance twin
power turbo 12 cylinder gasoline engine
the 6.6 liter motor generates a maximum
output of 448 kilowatts or 610
horsepower 20-inch light alloy wheels
help give the 5.24 meter high
performance sedan it's sporty look its
new M sports exhaust system with flap
control ensures a mighty v12 roar the M
760li X Drive also comes with an
automatic 8-speed steptronic sport
transmission DTM race car driver
Agosto far Foose is trying out the
167,000 euro BMW M 760li on Palm Springs
racetrack the 760 with this v12 engine
it has a lot of power a lot of torque
and just to give you an example from 0
to 100 clumps an hour my DTM car goes
around 3 seconds 3.1 seconds the 760 it
goes 3.7 and this is down to the launch
control system we have on the car and
the four-wheel drive the xDrive as I
said it just managed to pull you very
fast out of the corners
from engine speeds of 1500 rpm the car
has a maximum torque of 800 Newton
meters it's got an electronically
limited top speed of 250 kilometers an
hour but the optional M drivers package
will let you reach 305 kilometres an
hour the downside on average the BMW
consumes 12.8 litres per 100 kilometers
you have the electronic robots on the
car and the rhetoric robots helps to
keep always ideal balance in the corners
they act in order to keep the platform
stable and have a steering wheel
extremely precise the electronic
differential the X Drive it is a rear
wheel based traction but on top of that
you have always the car looking for the
optimum traction and as an example a
goon power and the carriages get out
from the corner without wheel spin
without drift and you see the automatic
gearbox how quick it is to upshift
really powerful brakes 19 inch brakes
which allows you to go very late on
brakes and no fading it is pretty
impressive that this is a 7 series and
you drive on track it's a race car those
who don't want the M 760 as a race car
but still come with a status symbol
cannot for the excellence model it comes
with plenty of chrome on the exterior
[Music]
given the vehicles dimensions there's
lots of room inside especially in the
back there's even a fancy footrest so we
have the turning rear wheels which helps
car to turn into sharp corners to
u-turns like here so I come I turn and I
feel that the car has no wonders here I
can go on power and the car stays on
track
and it's a perfect combination you can
have a very comfortable car to travel
the crew is using the torque of the
engine you can have a family car to go
shopping that is plenty of space but you
put everything on sport mode and this
car becomes very policy fast sharp like
a race car
fantastic
[Music]
[Music]
the third-generation mazda6 has been out
since 2013 and sold over half a million
cars in that time 80% of them outside
Europe every year Mazda has to spiff up
at 6:00 is a little for those
non-european buyers
they've come to expect it car tester
undulate Zimmermann has always been a
fan of the Mazda 6 anyway mainly because
it's so much fun to drive not in terms
of getting around the racetrack as fast
as possible but just in terms of
everyday transportation it's easy going
but fleet-footed one result of the
upgrade is that the engine is more
responsive our test car got 110
kilowatts of power from its skyactiv-d
150 diesel engine with 2.2 liters
capacity the starting price for the
nakooma trim line in Germany comes to
just under 35,000 euros the Mazda 6 is
sound proofing has been enhanced for the
2017 model year so we hear less of the
diesel engine even so when accelerating
the Mazda 6 can't entirely hide the
diesel under its hood but once you get
up to speed on a straightaway you can
almost forget that fact constant
aggressive indicator him glided done
can't mention first Ferguson as the
motor ABAB loyal to optimize the noise
levels Mazda concentrated mainly on the
lower speed ranges and it paid off on
the outside not much has changed the
turn signals in the mirrors have been
moved around to the front
[Music]
the safety systems have also been given
a rework a new high-definition camera on
the windshield is used for the drivers
assists for lane keeping high beams and
the smart city brake support andre
points out that the redesigned steering
wheel somewhat resembles the one in the
Mazda mx-5
it's also got thinner padding that
doesn't bother Andrei but someone is
certain to complain Andrei quite likes
the fact that it's heated too even if
it's just in the grips on the sides and
not the top or bottom that's naturally
new articles the longest length hutzpah
highest is unleashed there over going on
to the tire Mazda's engineers have also
fine-tune the handling but without
altering the suspension components the
car maker says new software for the
control module helps make for safer and
easier driving now Andrei comes to the
highlight of the upgrade the drivers
assistance system with a rather
spectacular named gene vectoring control
the system varies the engine torque to
shift the center of gravity it reduces
the torque when rounding corners which
moves the center of gravity forward and
improves the vehicle's cornering
behavior for greater stability coming
out of the curve it increases the torque
shifting the center of gravity toward
the rear
these are very particular details that
make all the difference Andre doesn't
think the mazda6 absolutely needed the
upgrade but he admits it's a clever move
on Mazdas part to do this annually
because it keeps the competition from
getting too much of a head start
[Music]
Smart has become the first automaker in
the world to offer its complete range of
models as electric cars the fourth
generation of the smart electric drive
includes a four seed version along with
a two-seater and the convertible the
battery and all smart vehicles is
located under the front seats it's
official range is 155 kilometres the
g650 Lundell a is the first off road
vehicle constructed by mercedes luxury
subdivision Maybach the addition is
limited to 99 cars and they come with a
muscular v12 motor an electrically
retractable canvas roof and a range of
luxury options with 463 kilowatts and a
maximum torque of no less than 1000
Newton meters the g650 could probably
towaway a tank the price has yet to be
set
[Music]
venison car Chester Emmanuelle Schaefer
is convinced if any car maker knows
about off-road driving it's cheap it's
off rotors have been rolling from the
assembly line for over 75 years now the
Grand Cherokees current fourth
generation has been going since 2010
there have been a few facelifts in that
time but our test car is no ordinary one
this Grand Cherokee in the trailhawk
line of options is available starting
with the 2017 model year
it's the variant best designed for
off-road driving as the reinforced skid
plates and the Quadra lift air
suspension confirm the trailhawk also
offers all-wheel drive with an
electronic limited slip rear
differential
[Music]
amanwe has learned that the
fifth-generation Grand Cherokee should
have replaced the current generation by
late last year and time for the 2018
models but sheep ran into development
delays the fifth-generation is supposed
to share his unibody platform with a
long-awaited new Wagoneer and it will
apparently take longer to achieve this
than originally planned
[Music]
cheap drivers no the Grand Cherokee not
only looks like an off-roader he says it
can really go off-road the trailhawk
version we tested even more so it's been
especially designed for rugged
conditions along with the additional
equipment the Trail Hawk Jeep sports
kevlar reinforced tires the Grand
Cherokee bridges to world's Town and
Country it's at home in both so you can
drive straight from snow clad mountains
forests to the Opera our test cars own
color scheme the redline is only
available for the trio Hawk
[Music]
higher ground clearance and good
traction are two of the five qualities
of vehicle needs to earn the trail rated
badging the matte black hood decal cuts
out glare a 3.6 liter Pentastar engine
puts out 213 kilowatts of power hurling
the SUV's 2.3 tons from 0 to 100 km/h
and 8.3 seconds average fuel consumption
is rated at 8 litres per 100 kilometers
our test car lists were about 62,000
euros in Germany
[Music]
they identified the driver Amana WA says
can turn the dial to various driving
modes while the Jeep is in motion
depending on the surface among other
things that sets the height of the air
suspension the Quadra lifts air
suspension offers five height settings
and plays a crucial role in the car's
adapting equally well to off-road or
city driving conditions from the back
that she looks very bit as beefy as from
the front
[Music]
the rear cargo area contains 782 liters
of space expanding the 1,550 litres with
the back seat folded down the interior
is fairly straightforward no frills but
arranged for easy operation
the 8.4 inch display is a touchscreen
[Music]
the combined leather velour seat
upholstery makes for a high-quality feel
and even the backseat passengers enjoy
heated seats plus USB ports to recharge
their mobile phones youngsters will
appreciate details like this
[Music]
right emanuelle has decided that for a
car that shouldn't even exist anymore
the 2017 facelifted Grand Cherokee cuts
a good figure
after all jeep knows how to build off
rotors and the trailhawk version is just
right for people who like to strike out
cross country for a real workhorse
eighty eight thousand euros will buy the
SRT equipment line and bring a piece of
the American dream to Europe this
version includes a six point four liter
v8 engine
[Music]
[Music]
if you don't want a Mercedes a BMW or an
Audi you still have plenty of options
we're in Copenhagen to check out the
many alternatives
we start with Scandinavian car maker
Volvo the s90 is very modern right down
to the last screw it's looks cool calm
and collected
Volvo is trying to escape being known
only for its station wagons it's new
sedan is bigger more than an S than an
eClass Mercedes this Swedish giant is
elegant and stylish
kudos to Volvo head designer Thomas
England lot and his team the S 90
combines a classic basic shape with
modern details
the interior has been painstakingly
designed using top-quality materials the
s9b is a good car for taking long trips
even though it only comes with a
four-cylinder engine we test-drove the
regular gas model with 187 kilowatts of
power migrate to the second Queen of
Denmark lives in a Malian borg palace
she'd probably be most captivated by the
Jaguar XF it definitely has a royal air
to it
the combination of leather aluminum and
luxury inlays is very British indeed
even though the automotive industry has
long done a brexit from the UK Jaguar is
part of the Indian Tata conglomerate but
that hasn't damaged the brand
technologically the Jaguar XF is every
bit the equal of its rivals it's quiet
and understated but the 221 kilowatt
diesel engine is quick off the mark the
easy shifting 8th gear automatic
transmission on the other hand is rather
reserved this Jaguar is a pussycat with
some sharp claws
the opposite of the Jaguar comes from
Bella Italia Maserati is famous for
stirring up excitement and who hasn't
moved by the Ghibli Ghibli the famous
Maserati super sports car from the 1960s
back then eight cylinder engines were
must
the Ghibli sedan car may only have a v6
but on the other hand the engine is a
Ferrari thanks to its bi turbo the
engine has 301 kilowatts of pump and the
Ghibli is anything but d'amour the
top-of-the-line sq4 model has all-wheel
drive and its handling on the asphalt is
beyond reproach it's a high-performance
sports car with four doors the interior
is like an immaculate Armani suit
featuring perfectly contoured seats and
leather everywhere
the tradition of alta Mota is alive and
well and speaking of tradition Alfa
Romeo is back reports of the demise of
this venerable brand name were greatly
exaggerated the new Giulia is a classic
Alfa that bewitches drivers not just
with its looks
but above all with its performance it
features a sideways mounted motor and
rear-wheel drive the chassis is ideal
not too hard and not too soft
the Giulia has also been put together
really well no rattling or scraping
noises here the design of the interior
is nothing short of grand the new Giulia
could become a new cash cow for Alfa the
one element that doesn't fit in is the
diesel motor
[Music]
wex s is Toyota's luxury brand and it's
known for its use of hybrid technologies
Lexus vehicles have been overshadowed
somewhat by German luxury sedans that
could change with its unmistakable front
grille the GS 450h is mounting a
challenge for dominance of this market
sector the Lexus is as comfortable as
the Jaguar and is precisely built as the
Volvo all it lacks is the sportiness of
the two Italian models it's ace in the
hole is its ultra efficient engine
according to Lexus the GS 450h consumes
only 5.9 liters of gas per hundred
kilometers people looking for prestige
sedan cars outside the German market are
spoiled for choice
venerable brand names like Alfa Maserati
and Jaguar have made the transition into
the 21st century Volvo has landed a huge
success with the S 90 which combines
fantastic design with the latest
technology the lexus makes its case with
the longevity of its super efficient
hybrid technology these five luxury
sedans are much like the Copenhagen
itself a city that pairs tradition with
no shortage of modernity
[Music]
back in the 1950s Western Europe was in
a post-war recovery boom more people
could now afford the nicer things in
life and in the automotive world that
meant exclusive cupisz and convertibles
Carman always specialized in open top
cars explains our car reviewer
christophe the us know Brooke based
Coach maker turned out its first slick
looking convertibles in coupe A's in
1902 for all manner of car makers but
it's moment of real glory came in 1958
with a Volkswagen Karmann Ghia named dan
for the coach maker that actually built
it and rightly so because the car would
never have materialized that had not
been for Vilhelm carmen junior company
chief and son of its founder in the
early 1950s he persuaded VW bus finally
Nordhoff to put together a prototype la
dolce vita from osnabrück declares
christophe the design of the Karmann
Ghia was most unusual for a West German
car in the 1950s that is no surprise to
see an Italian behind it gyah head
designer Luigi Ceglie Wilhelm Carmen
secretly asked him to put a beautiful
metal shell onto a used Beetle chassis
in 1953 VW's hard-nosed boss heinrich
nord wolf looked at the prototype and
loved it that Karmann Ghia went into
production
[Music]
the coupe a got the undertaking rolling
in 1955 this old advertisement shows
workers polishing the Carmen by hand the
message was clear the new Volkswagen
promised exclusivity elegance and
dynamic handling at an affordable price
the car was also marketed in the US
[Music]
that said the Carmen Diaz performance
always trail behind the promise of its
dynamic appearance although good looks
can get you a long way
bundle and just look at those curves
it's as if the car were cast from one
block of metal and it is the door isn't
hood or bolted on but otherwise all the
body parts are welded together that
translates into high torsional stiffness
but on the other hand every single
repair job on this very rust-proof body
requires a blowtorch once I subpoena
keep that onyx
many people consider the Karmann Ghia
the best-looking Volkswagen of all time
the contours are perfection and a
veritable delight for the eyes and
there's a range of other loving details
that make the car a pleasure just to
look at let alone drive
[Music]
the Carmen has 32 kilowatts of power and
Sprint's to 100 km/h in a leisurely 23
seconds top speed is 136 km/h
[Music]
it's unless but in Tom the car was
especially popular with the ladies
explains christophe earning it the
naughty nickname housewives porsche it
is 20 kilometers per hour faster than
the beetle thanks to its aerodynamics
but it's worlds away from a porsche
a marriage of spectacular design and
conventional production car engineering
the Karmann Ghia was the manifestation
of an ingenious concept one that
Volkswagen and Porsche would further
develop to acclaim with a 914 and 924
models the Karmann Ghia deserves a lot
of credit in christoph sighs it was a
breath of fresh air to West Germany's
post-war streets and the styling also
opened up opportunities for other
Italian designers in the German car
industry and that's enough reason to
call the Karmann Ghia a milestone in
automotive history
my ultimate vacancies did the Karmann
Ghia was in production for almost two
decades from 1955 to 1974 it was the
first time automobile old cooter was
available for the man on the street to
[Music]
[Music]